This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。100%纯人类。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪现代世界中，关于心理韧性、健身以及培养抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即数字“2”加percent，在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方。在《Look Back at It》播客节目中。从1979年开始，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·恩格斯。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的嘉宾包括朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听Look Back at It。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个节目探讨的是黑人男性的经历，进行一些在其他地方真的不太安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的执照专业人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着一身盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须使用它。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听并学习《Learn the Hard Way》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个同性恋。迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello, everybody, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the podcast. the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，在这个播客中，我们探讨20多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转型，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。
Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. You know, the deal. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, we are talking about a word, we are talking about a topic, a concept that carries a whole lot of weight, but is also used pretty flippantly in conversation and is very misunderstood. We are talking about trauma. Specifically, I really want to talk about how trauma is not just emotional, not just psychological or cognitive, but physical as well. This is something that in my own personal life, I've been doing a lot of deep research, deep knowledge searching on trying to find the best resources, trying to find personal experiences, trying to find the best books about how trauma is essentially trapped in the body. Long story short, I feel like I've had a lot of realizations about the kind of rage and anger that I carry in my body, about the kind of kind of, irritation that I'm constantly carrying around, the tension, all of these like reactions that I have to certain situations that I literally have no idea where it came from. I've just kind of always
大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。你知道的。很高兴你能回来收听新的一集，当然，我们今天要剖析的是20多岁的心理学。今天，我们要探讨一个词，我们要讨论一个话题、一个概念，它承载着非常沉重的分量，但在日常对话中却被相当轻率地使用，并且受到了极大的误解。我们要谈论的是创伤。具体来说，我真的很想谈谈创伤不仅是情感上的、不仅是心理或认知上的，而且还是身体上的。在我的个人生活中，我一直在对此进行深入的研究、寻找深度的知识，试图找到最好的资源，试图寻找个人的经验，试图找到关于创伤本质上如何被困在身体里的最好的书籍。长话短说，我觉得我有很多感悟：关于我身体里承载的那种愤怒和狂怒，关于我一直随身携带的那种烦躁，那种紧张，所有这些我对某些情况的反应，我简直不知道它们是从哪里来的。我只是觉得
been frustrated by until I started to really sit with past experiences and sit with trauma and just kind of appreciate how, you know, it's not just psychological, it's not just in my mind, it's not just something that happened to me, but it has had like real long-term behavioral and physical. I don't want to say consequences, but implications. And it just felt like the appropriate time to kind of take all that knowledge and that research that I've been doing and put it into an episode so that hopefully it's helpful for some of you guys out there. Those of you who are in their 20s like me, who are maybe figuring this out for the first time or even if you are older. Now, I know that the word trauma, it can feel really big, it can feel very clinical, very intense, you know, for a long time. I didn't think that it applied to me.
一直对此感到沮丧，直到我开始真正去正视过去的经历，去正视创伤，并开始领会，你知道的，它不仅仅是心理上的，它不仅仅存在于我的脑海中，它也不仅仅是发生在我身上的某件事，而是对我的长期行为和生理产生了实实在在的。我不想说是后果，但确实是影响。我觉得现在是时候把这些知识和一直在做的研究整合起来，做成一集节目，希望对你们中的一些人有所帮助。那些像我一样正处于20多岁、可能正在摸索这一切的人，或者甚至是年长的人。现在，我知道“创伤”这个词可能会让人觉得很大、很具临床感、非常强烈，你知道的，很长一段时间里。我并不认为它适用于我。
I hadn't survived a war. I hadn't lived through some giant film screen worthy event. You know, my childhood was pretty normal. But this term and this concept means a lot more than I think we have. have been taught it means. And it is a lot less limited than previous definitions or previous understandings of this experience would make us believe. It's one of those terms that we hear a lot.
我没有经历过战争。我也没有经历过什么值得搬上电影银幕的宏大事件。你知道的，我的童年很正常。但这个词和这个概念的含义，远比我们以往被教导的要丰富得多。它远没有以前对这种经历的定义或理解那么局限。这是我们经常听到的一个术语。
And then I feel like a lot of us still don't think that it applies to us. We have to have lived through something really obvious and something very obviously painful at the time to be part of this group or part of this category of humans. who have experienced trauma. I think also we tend to sometimes judge the pain of a past experience by the symptoms that we have now or how much that pain is carried forward. So, you know, if we're not having a seemingly big reaction to something that's happened in the past, well, then that experience mustn't have been as traumatic as we thought it was.
然后我觉得我们中的很多人仍然认为这不适用于我们。我们必须经历过非常明显的事情，而且在当时是非常明显痛苦的事情，才能成为经历过创伤的人类这个群体或类别的一部分。我想我们有时也倾向于根据我们现在的症状，或者这种痛苦在多大程度上延续到了今天，来衡量过去经历的痛苦。所以，你知道的，如果我们对过去发生的事情没有看似巨大的反应，那么，这种经历一定不像我们想象的那么具有创伤性。
But the thing with realizing how trauma is stored in the body is you also start to realize how almost unconscious and invisible a trauma response or the long-term impacts of trauma actually are. Because we often think about it purely as this like emotional response, but it is deeply, deeply physical. It shows up in tension. It shows up in chronic pain. It shows up in fatigue. It shows up in these like immediate behavioral reactions that we have no control over. You know, crying when someone raises their voice, even if like they're not actually angry. Trauma is stored in your nervous system. It's stored in your gut reaction. It's stored in how you breathe. It's the famous book. Your body keeps the score even when your brain tries to move on.
但认识到创伤是如何储存在身体里这一问题时，你也会开始意识到，创伤反应或创伤的长期影响实际上是多么的无意识和隐蔽。因为我们通常认为它纯粹是一种情绪反应，但它却是极其深层的生理反应。它表现为紧张。它表现为慢性疼痛。它表现为疲劳。它表现为我们无法控制的那些即兴行为反应。你知道的，当有人提高嗓门时就会哭，哪怕他们其实并没有生气。创伤储存在你的神经系统中。它储存在你的应激反应中。它储存在你的呼吸方式中。正如那本著名的书所说：即使你的大脑试图继续前行，你的身体也会铭记一切。
So in this episode, I really want to talk about what trauma really is, what happens within us when we experience traumatic, something traumatic, even if we don't acknowledge or know that it was traumatic at the time and how we kind of get stuck in a chronic arousal or chronic stress mode that we don't even realize. I also want to talk about how small moments from the past really shape our sense of safety, our identity, our sense of connection, how we relate to other people as well in, again, ways that are often quite invisible and not acknowledged. I'm going to say this episode it's not going to try and pathologize every single experience that you've had. And it's not going to say that if you have trauma, that's it.
所以在这一集里，我真的很想讨论什么是真正的创伤，当我们经历创伤时，我们内部会发生什么，即使我们在当时并没有意识到或知道那是创伤，以及我们如何陷入一种我们甚至没有意识到的慢性觉醒或慢性应激模式。我还想谈谈过去的微小时刻是如何真正塑造我们的安全感、我们的身份认同、我们的连接感，以及我们与他人建立关系的方式，同样，这些方式往往是相当隐蔽且不被承认的。我要说的是，这集节目不会试图将你经历过的每一个微小的体验都进行病理化。它也不会说如果你有创伤，那就这样了。
It will always be there. This is who you are. Instead, I just hope you understand yourself and your body better through this discussion and what it may be holding and storing for you, what it may be hiding so that you continue to feel like you are strong and that you are capable enough. I think this episode is really about acknowledging that you can be soft and you can be gentle and you can be vulnerable and that doesn't mean that the trauma has won. It's meant that actually you have and you've acknowledged its impact on you.
它会永远存在。这就是你。相反，我只是希望通过这次讨论，你能更好地理解自己和你的身体，了解它可能为你承载和储存了什么，它可能在隐藏着什么，这样你就能继续觉得自己是坚强的，并且有足够的能力。我认为这一集实际上是为了承认你可以是柔软的，你可以是温柔的，你可以是脆弱的，这并不意味着创伤已经赢了。这意味着实际上你赢了，你承认了它对你的影响。
So a lot of thoughts, a lot to unpack here, a lot of science, a lot of research that I have been searching through and digging through for many, many months, maybe even years at this stage. So we're going to take a deep breath and we're going to get into exploring exactly how trauma is trapped in the body. Stay with us. So before we get into how trauma, gets trapped in our bodies, we need to talk about what trauma really means, which is actually kind of tricky because by its very nature, trauma actually means very different things for very different people and it's very hard to categorize. But psychologists have given it a go,
所以，有很多想法，这里有很多内容需要剖析，有很多科学，有很多研究，是我几个月来，甚至在这个阶段可能是几年里一直在搜寻和挖掘的。所以我们要深吸一口气，开始深入探讨创伤究竟是如何被困在身体里的。请继续收听。因此，在我们探讨创伤是如何被困在我们的身体里之前，我们需要讨论一下创伤的真正含义，这其实有点棘手，因为就其本质而言，创伤对不同的人来说意味着非常不同的事情，而且很难分类。但心理学家们已经做出了尝试，
researchers have given it a go, and there are a couple of ways that they see or I hate to say it, but rank trauma. Firstly, the big type of trauma we often think of is a large, significant one-time life-threatening event, like a natural disaster, a car accident, a near-death experience. This is what we call type 1 trauma. These moments, they just flip life on its head. They're unexpected. They come out of nowhere. And the reason they are so traumatic is because they make us realize how inherently unsafe we
研究人员也做出了尝试，他们看待或我不想这么说，但对创伤进行分级的方法有几种。首先，我们经常想到的那种重大创伤，是一个巨大的、显著的、一生只有一次的威胁生命的事件，比如自然灾害、车祸、濒死体验。这就是我们所说的一型创伤。这些时刻，它们简直把生活颠倒了过来。它们是意料之外的。它们凭空出现。它们之所以如此具有创伤性，是因为它们让我们意识到作为人类，我们本质上是多么的不安全，
are as humans, how vulnerable we are. And they cause us to really have to rethink our lives and also rethink how we can return to a point where we feel safe and stable, which is very hard for people. These moments, I think, are very clearly traumatic in the eyes of many people in the eyes of society. They are not the only trauma that occurs. Smaller, repeated traumatic events over time or prolonged exposure to traumatic situations are another type of trauma we call type two trauma. Type two trauma includes things like having maybe a violent, childhood home or experiencing domestic violence, but even things like racism, discrimination,
我们是多么的脆弱。它们让我们不得不重新思考我们的生活，同时也重新思考我们如何才能回到一个让我们感到安全和稳定的状态，这对人们来说是非常困难的。在许多人眼中，在社会眼中，这些时刻显然是具有创伤性的。它们并不是唯一的创伤。随着时间的推移，更小的、重复的创伤事件，或者长期暴露在创伤情境中，是另一种类型的创伤，我们称之为二型创伤。二型创伤包括诸如拥有一个暴力的童年家庭或经历家庭暴力，甚至包括种族主义、歧视、
sexism, workplace harassment, chronic health conditions, all things that over time reduce our sense of safety and make us feel like we are not in control of our life or our environment or our surroundings. You know, I've got to say in 2019, I don't think I've ever talked about this on the podcast before, but I survived the Australian bushfires in an evacuation zone. And I genuinely thought the house was going to burn down. I could not call my family. I was absolutely terrified. I remember driving through like an active bushfire zone. The smell of smoke being like everywhere. It was so loud. That was traumatic. But it was not as traumatic to me as when my boss at the restaurant I worked at in the same year was intimidating me and harassing me. Even if from
性别歧视、职场骚扰、慢性健康状况，所有这些随着时间的推移都会降低我们的安全感，让我们觉得我们无法掌控自己的生活、环境或周围的一切。你知道的，我不得不说，在2019年，我觉得我以前从未在播客中谈论过这件事，但我曾在疏散区幸免于澳大利亚丛林大火。我当时真的以为房子会被烧毁。我无法给家人打电话。我感到绝对的恐慌。我记得自己开车穿过活跃的丛林大火区。到处都是烟味。声音太大了。那是具有创伤性的。但对我来说，它甚至不如同年我在工作的餐馆里遭到老板恐吓和骚扰时受到的创伤大。即使从
the outside, you know, those bushfires are the thing that people remember. To me, like, when I look back at my life and I'm like, oh, what has really like left a scar? It's not that. It's this smaller, repeated situation that made me feel a lot more unsafe day to day than the big natural disaster that I live through. The focus on trauma, what I'm trying to say here is that it's less on the magnitude of the event itself and more on our own personal response to it. And that's often influenced by things like previous experiences, previous personal experiences, upbringing, even like our DNA and how stress is encoded into our DNA. A lot of the time, I think we tend to dismiss our own trauma because it's not big and bad enough compared to what others have gone through. It feels like there is this ladder almost or this pyramid of how we rank trauma.
外部来看，你知道的，那些丛林大火是人们记住的事情。对我来说，当我回首往事并心想，哦，究竟是什么真正留下了伤疤？不是那个。而是这个更小的、重复出现的情况，它让我比我经历过的大自然灾害在日常生活中感到更不安全。这里我想说的是，对创伤的关注点较少放在事件本身的规模上，而更多地放在我们自己对它的个人反应上。而这通常受到诸如以往经历、过去的个人经历、成长经历，甚至我们的DNA以及压力是如何编码到我们的DNA中等因素的影响。很多时候，我觉得我们往往会淡化自己的创伤，因为与其他人所经历的相比，它还不够大、不够糟糕。感觉几乎存在着这样一架阶梯或金字塔，用来对创伤进行分级。
And if we're not at the top of the pyramid experiencing the very worst of what humanity and life can throw at us, then we don't belong in the category of someone who has trauma. And here's the thing I always say to this. Someone can have a broken leg and you can have a broken arm and your broken arm is still going to hurt. Like, just because someone has more pain than you doesn't mean that your pain isn't being subjectively experienced as painful. Someone could have more trauma than you. it doesn't mean that the trauma you're experiencing isn't just as awful. Like it's this weird thing where our bodies and our minds can continue to adapt to really,
如果我们没有处于金字塔的顶端，去经历人性与生活所能抛出的最糟糕的事情，那么我们就不属于经历过创伤的人这一类别。而这就是我对此一直以来的看法。一个人可能腿断了，而你可能胳膊断了，但你断了的手臂依然会痛。就像，仅仅是因为别人比你承受了更多的痛苦，并不意味着你正在经历的痛苦不具痛苦性。可能有人比你承受了更多的创伤。但这并不意味着你正在经历的创伤同样不糟糕。就像这是一个奇怪的事情，我们的身体和大脑可以继续适应非常、
really terrible, terrible things. And our pain threshold or our trauma threshold gets bigger and bigger and bigger. It doesn't mean that the threshold that you had when you experience your trauma wasn't already at a point where pain was going to be experienced. I feel like that's a really complicated way of explaining it. But hopefully what I mean and what you interpret from that is that this is an entirely subjective experience. What constitutes a traumatic event for one person may not for another, depending on their individual biology, their psychological resilience, their support system. You know, you could be in a car accident. You could walk away and be completely unfazed, but someone else might not be able to ever get back in a car.
非常糟糕、糟糕的事情。我们的痛阈或创伤阈值变得越来越大。但这并不意味着当你经历创伤时所拥有的阈值还没有达到会让人感到痛苦的程度。我觉得这是一种非常复杂的解释方式。但希望我的意思以及你从中解读出的含义是，这是一个完全主观的体验。对一个人来说构成创伤性事件的事情，对另一个人可能并非如此，这取决于他们各自的生物学特征、心理韧性以及支持系统。你知道的，你可能会遇到车祸。你可能会安然无恙地走开，完全没有受到影响，但另一个人可能再也无法坐进车里。
You know, as compared to, you know, someone may be in a situation they see as life threatening. another person wouldn't see it as life-threatening. Whose definition of life-threatening do we therefore follow? And also, sometimes something doesn't need to have threatened your physical safety to be traumatic, you know, as is the case with vicarious trauma. A person working in an emergency department could be entirely safe from actual danger themselves, but still leave that workplace five years later, deeply traumatized. The point is, if we're looking for some kind of yardstick or questionnaire
你知道的，相比之下，你知道的，一个人可能会处于他们认为会威胁生命的情况中。而另一个人可能不会认为这会威胁生命。因此，我们到底遵循谁对“威胁生命”的定义？而且，有时有些事情并不需要威胁到你的身体安全才具有创伤性，你知道的，就像替代性创伤（间接创伤）的情况一样。在急诊室工作的医务人员可能自身完全免受实际危险的侵害，但在五年后离开该工作岗位时，仍然受到深深的创伤。关键是，如果我们正在寻找某种衡量标准或问卷，
as to whether a situation was traumatic and whether you're looking for a questionnaire or a yardstick that is universal and will apply to everyone, we aren't going to find one. And yes, that may mean that some people may call something traumatic that you wouldn't. But I would much rather, even the smallest things, be labelled as traumatic and be treated with grace and gentleness and care, then one person not receive the acknowledgement they need for their trauma because they think it's too small to count. People can disagree with me on this and say, well, that invalidates people who were actually traumatized and who have actually lived through terrible things, to which I always say,
来判断某个情况是否具有创伤性，以及如果你在寻找一种普遍的、适用于所有人的问卷或衡量标准，我们是找不到的。是的，这可能意味着有些人可能会把某些你不会觉得是创伤的事情称之为创伤。但我宁愿即使是最小的事情也被贴上创伤的标签，并受到优雅、温柔和关怀的对待，也不愿某个人因为认为自己的创伤太小而得不到他们所需要的认可。人们可以在这一点上不同意我的看法，并说这否定了那些真正受过创伤、真正经历过可怕事情的人，对此我总是说，
who is determining what actually means? And secondly, we're focusing on the wrong thing. Why are we focusing on excluding people from the trauma definition when we should be focused on reducing shame for all people, expanding resources, expanding, expanding how we collectively think of trauma as a systemic issue and as a community issue, where we need to support each other and, you know, hold each other accountable to not harm other people. Like, I think we're focusing on the wrong thing when we're trying to get people to jump over a certain hurdle to be considered as traumatized.
谁来决定“真正”意味着什么？其次，我们关注错了重点。当我们应该专注于减少所有人的羞耻感、扩大资源、扩大我们对创伤的集体认知——将其视为一个系统性问题和一个社区问题，我们需要互相支持，并追究彼此不伤害他人的责任时，为什么我们要专注于将人们排除在创伤的定义之外？就像，我认为当我们试图让人们跨越某个门槛以便被认为是受到创伤时，我们关注的方向就错了。
It's also important to note as well that often the signs of trauma don't immediately show themselves. The same way that a bruise doesn't immediately appear on the skin after you've experienced like a blunt force trauma injury. This is known as delayed trauma onset and it's a lot more common than we think, especially with childhood trauma because our trauma response is often delayed by the fact that we may not have the cognitive abilities to process what happened or the words to explain what happened until our brain catches up later on. also a lot of times people are experiencing traumatic things and the only way they can get through that traumatic experience is to completely dissociate from the fact that it is happening to them. So it's only once they feel a maybe minor or general sense of psychological safety or environmental safety and they are out of that situation that they are able to appreciate like, hey, that was really messed up.
同样重要的是要注意，创伤的迹象往往不会立即显现出来。就像你在遭受钝器伤后，皮肤上不会立即出现瘀伤一样。这被称为创伤延迟发作，它比我们想象的要普遍得多，尤其是童年创伤，因为我们的创伤反应常常被延迟，原因是我们可能没有认知能力来处理发生的事情，或者没有言语来解释发生的事情，直到后来我们的大脑追赶上来。而且很多时候，人们正在经历创伤性事情，他们能够度过那段创伤经历的唯一方法就是完全抽离出这件事正发生在他身上的事实。因此，只有当他们感受到某种微小或普遍的心理安全感或环境安全感，并且脱离了那种情境时，他们才能够体会到，嘿，那真的很糟糕。
Like that really shouldn't have happened to me. It happens a lot of times with relationships or a lot of times, again, with childhood where you are living under your parents' roots. You are living in a house. You do not have the independence and the agency to escape that situation when you're a child. So you just have to really, like, bury deep into whatever coping mechanism you may have available to you, one of those being a complete dismissal of your circumstances. A 2020 paper out of Australia actually found that a lot of, of people have this experience. A lot of people report this delayed trauma onset. And they also say that,
就像那真的不应该发生在我身上一样。这种情况在恋爱关系中经常发生，或者同样在童年时期，你寄人篱下。你住在一所房子里。作为一个孩子，你没有逃离那种境地的独立性和自主权。所以你只能深深地埋头于你手头可能拥有的任何应对机制中，其中之一就是彻底无视你的处境。澳大利亚2020年的一篇论文实际上发现，许多人都有这种经历。许多人都报告了这种创伤延迟发作。他们还表示，
you know, the signs that they've been through something really difficult only became more noticeable at a certain stage or phase in their life. You know, they didn't realize how their childhood had impacted them until they got into their first serious adult relationship. And suddenly it was like, wow, I am a deeply wounded human being. You know, you don't realize how much much the death of your parent impacted you until your family pet dies. You don't process how much the bullying you experienced as a child really sat with you until, you know, you're in your 30s and you weren't invited on like the Bachelorette trip and suddenly you're 13 again and all that anxiety and all that social claustrophobia and all that fomo is back. But potentially one of the
你知道的，他们经历过艰难事情的迹象，直到他们生命中的某个特定阶段或时期才变得更加明显。你知道的，直到你进入第一段认真的成年恋爱关系时，你才意识到童年是如何影响你的，突然间，就好像是，哇，我是一个深受创伤的人。你知道的，直到你的宠物去世，你才意识到父母的离世对你产生了多大的影响。直到你三十多岁、没有被邀请去参加单身派对时，你才真正处理好儿时遭受的霸凌是如何深深留在你心里的，然后突然间你又回到了13岁，所有的焦虑、所有的社交幽闭恐惧症和所有的错失恐惧症（FOMO）都回来了。但可能其中一个
biggest ways trauma starts to show up for us later on in life or even immediately after a traumatic event and the whole theme of today's episode is that it begins to show up physically through the body. Basically, you suppress all of this stuff emotionally and psychologically and the only outlet it has is physically. And so it starts to kind of like trickle out through tension, through fatigue, through pain. This is the semantic impact of trauma, the semantic response to trauma. And of course, we cannot talk about this without firstly acknowledging the book that really put this on the map, which is the body keeps the score. Very, very famous. I think it is, I think it's sold like three million copies worldwide. It was written by a very famous
创伤开始在晚年甚至在创伤事件发生后不久开始对我们显现的最大方式——也是今天这集节目的整个主题——是它开始通过身体显现出来。基本上，你在情感和心理上压抑了所有这些东西，它唯一的宣泄口就是通过生理。因此，它开始通过紧张、疲劳、疼痛一点点渗漏出来。这就是创伤的躯体影响，对创伤的躯体反应。当然，我们不能不首先承认那本真正让这本书名声大噪的书，也就是《身体不会忘记》（The Body Keeps the Score）。非常、非常著名。我想它在全球大约售出了三百万册。它是由一位非常著名的
Dutch psychiatrist, Dr. Bessel van der Kolk. I hopefully I pronounce that. I don't speak Dutch, but I think that's right. I think it's been on the New York Times best sell list for like six years now. Everyone knows this book. You have seen it before. It's safe to say this has just like completely changed how we think about trauma. The core premise of this book is that trauma isn't just this story we tell in our minds. It's not just memories. It's actually stored in our bodies.
荷兰精神病学家，贝塞尔·范德科克（Bessel van der Kolk）博士撰写的。希望我发音正确。我不会说荷兰语，但我想应该是这样。我想它在《纽约时报》畅销书排行榜上已经呆了六年了。每个人都知道这本书。你以前一定见过它。可以说，这本书彻底改变了我们对创伤的思考方式。这本书的核心前提是，创伤不仅仅是我们脑海中讲述的故事。它不仅仅是记忆。它实际上储存在我们的身体里。
When we experience something traumatic, our brain and our nervous system are significantly impacted in a way that can leave us physically stuck in the past. because our mind and our body, like their relationship cannot be disentangled. Something happens that shakes us mentally and emotionally. That doesn't happen in isolation. Our body is also wrapped up in this. Prior to this book coming out, the clinical conversation and the general social conversation around trauma often centered on the cognitive side of things and on cognitive behavioral therapy, which really placed an importance on the idea of changing thought patterns.
当我们经历创伤时，我们的大脑和神经系统会受到显著影响，这种影响可能会使我们在身体上陷入过去无法自拔。因为我们的心智和身体，它们的关系是无法解耦的。发生了在精神和情感上震撼我们的事情。这并不是孤立发生的。我们的身体也卷入了其中。在这本书出版之前，关于创伤的临床讨论和普遍社会讨论往往集中在认知方面以及认知行为疗法上，后者非常重视改变思维模式的想法，
in order to change feelings. And it doesn't so much acknowledge the body is part of this. And this work, this book, really shifted the paradigm from the idea that trauma is something purely cognitive to the notion of this mind-body link. The brilliance of this book is that it gave people the language to understand things that perhaps a doctor had never given them the words to understand, things that the medical community or more traditional medical community had never been able to explain for them. their chronic pain, the way their body was responding to certain environmental cues,
以此来改变感受。它并没有那么承认身体是其中的一部分。而这部作品、这本书，真正将范式从“创伤纯粹是认知层面的”这一观点，转变为了“心身连接”的概念。这本书的伟大之处在于，它赋予了人们一种语言去理解那些可能医生从未赋予他们词汇去理解的事情，那些医学界或更传统的医学界从未能为他们解释的事情。他们的慢性疼痛，他们的身体对某些环境线索的反应方式，
their stomach issues, their nausea, their, like, fatigue. None of this was random. None of this was an accident. So it's definitely safe to say that the body keeps the score has been very important in this discussion, but there have been a few criticisms, which is why I talk about this book, but I always talk about it, kind of with, like, kind of with a little bit of, like, skepticism. it definitely got some things not wrong that may be a little bit misconstrued. You know, there was an editorial published in 2023 in the research on social work practice
他们的胃部问题，他们的恶心感，比如他们的疲劳。这些都不是随机的。这些都不是意外。所以绝对可以肯定地说，《身体不会忘记》在这次讨论中非常重要，但也有一些批评意见，这就是为什么我谈论这本书时，总是带有一点、带有那么一点点的怀疑态度。它确实有一些内容说得不完全对，可能有些被曲解了。你知道的，2023年在《社会工作实践研究》（Research on Social Work Practice）杂志上发表了一篇社论，
that highlighted that for many people with PTSD, the body keeps the score is deeply revealing for them, but it doesn't always give them accurate recommendations about where to go from there. And it often, when it does, it introduces people to these very, like intense themes and very intense ideas and then makes it seem like you can kind of DIY it, that you can DIY some of the therapeutic techniques that are introduced in this book. And that's not the case. Like this stuff needs to be performed or introduced through a trained practitioner. And we don't want people to, you know, read this book or what this article says is they don't want people to read this book and then think that somatic techniques are the
其中强调，对于许多患有PTSD（创伤后应激障碍）的人来说，《身体不会忘记》具有深刻的启示意义，但它并不总是能为他们提供关于接下来该去哪里的准确建议。而且很多时候，当它提供建议时，它会将人们引入这些非常强烈的主题和非常强烈的想法中，然后让人觉得你可以自己DIY（动手做），你可以自己动手做这本书中介绍的一些治疗技术。但事实并非如此。这些东西需要通过训练有素的从业者来执行或引入。我们不希望人们，你知道的，读这本书或者这篇文章所说的是，他们不希望人们读了这本书然后认为躯体技术是
only thing that's going to help them. It's often a lot more complex. Another article I read on the site, Mother Jones, it also suggested that this book really stigmatizes survivors and it blames victims by making the trauma and individual issue, not considering the fact that there are these huge social and political systems that are actually responsible. Instead of looking at the social context, for example, things like systemic racism or poverty or structural violence or deep misogyny and how these shape trauma, the book really focuses on how you as an individual can heal through semantic practices. And throughout the book, if you've read it, this may have given you the ick as well, but the author portrays, you know, survivors as self-sabotaging,
唯一能帮助他们的东西。情况往往要复杂得多。我在Mother Jones网站上读到的另一篇文章也暗示，这本书实际上污名化了幸存者，并通过将创伤变成一个个人问题而指责受害者，却根本没有考虑到存在着这些负有实际责任的巨大社会和政治系统。例如，该书没有去审视社会背景，如系统性种族主义、贫困、结构性暴力或深层的厌女症以及这些是如何塑造创伤的，而是真正关注你作为一个个人如何通过躯体实践来治愈。在整本书中，如果你读过它的话，这可能也会让你感到反感，但作者将幸存者描绘成自我毁灭的、
as not willing to take responsibility for their trauma without actually acknowledging the fact that can they really take accountability for their trauma when it was caused by a system and a context that hasn't taken accountability itself and that continues to retramatize them and continues to keep them down? What this has the danger of implying is that it is your personal responsibility to deal with trauma, to heal from trauma and to do that alone. And if you aren't able to do that, that is a person. or failing. And that means that you weren't disciplined enough, you didn't try hard enough,
不愿为自己的创伤承担责任的人，却没有真正承认这样一个事实：当创伤是由一个自身没有承担责任、继续对他们进行二次创伤并继续让他们陷入困境的系统和背景所引起时，他们真的能为自己的创伤承担责任吗？这有可能暗示的危险在于，处理创伤、从创伤中治愈并独自做到这一点是你的个人责任。如果你做不到这一点，那就是个人的失败。这意味着你不够纪律严明、你不够努力、
you were self-sabotaging when that is just like seriously not the case. And also seriously unhelpful because, you know, trauma takes a long time to overcome. Some people never overcome it. Sometimes it's just something you live with. But if you're in those early stages and you're feeling like nothing is working and you're reading this book that's like, if you can't manage this, then you're not trying hard enough or you're not taking enough responsibility. It's like, well, that's going to be deeply discouraging. So I just think that that is something that people should really understand. When reading this work, I know it is a huge introduction to this idea of how trauma is trapped in the body.
你在自我毁灭，而这根本就不是事实。而且也绝对没有帮助，因为你知道的，创伤需要很长时间才能克服。有些人永远无法克服它。有时它只是你生活中的一部分。但如果你正处于早期阶段，感觉没有任何方法奏效，而你正在读这样一本书，它说如果你无法控制这一点，那就是你不够努力，或者你没有承担足够的责任，那么这将会是非常令人沮丧的。所以我认为这是人们在阅读这部作品时真正应该理解的事情。我知道它是了解“创伤如何被困在身体里”这一理念的绝佳入门读物。
But there are also amazing other works and other books that you can read on this. Trauma and Recovery by Judith Herman is a great one. The book by Stephanie Fu, What My Bones Know, Also Amazing. If you got a lot out of the body keeps the score and want to expand your knowledge or you haven't read that book yet, those are some other really amazing like entry points to this discussion. So the body keeps the score an amazing introduction to this concept. It has like, it's done amazing work in terms of introducing people to this like mind-body relationship that we all have. But I want to kind of go a little bit further and explaining why exactly that is the case. and how to manage it perhaps in a more collective space as well.
但也有其他非常棒的作品和其他你可以阅读的书籍。朱ディ斯·赫尔曼（Judith Herman）的《创伤与恢复》（Trauma and Recovery）是一本好书。傅Stephanie Fu的书《What My Bones Know》也棒极了。如果你从《身体不会忘记》中收获颇丰并希望扩展你的知识，或者你还没有读过那本书，这些都是进行这次讨论的一些非常棒的切入点。所以《身体不会忘记》是这个概念的绝佳入门。它在将人们引入我们都具有的这种心身关系方面，做了出色的工作。但我想更进一步，解释为什么会出现这种情况，以及如何在更集中的空间里来管理它。
So we are going to take a short break here, but when we return, I want to talk about the exact biological, psychological, neurological mechanisms behind how trauma gets trapped in the body and also how we can start to release some of that tension and some of those physical effects. Stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs
所以我们在这里做一个简短的休息，但当我们回来时，我想讨论创伤如何被困在身体里的确切生物学、心理学、神经学机制，以及我们如何开始释放其中一些紧张情绪和生理影响。请继续收听。《2%》。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。
when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out that in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the
我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪现代世界中，关于心理韧性、健身以及培养抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即数字“2”加percent，在
IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does that? George Bush got to do a little kill. Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。这到底是怎么回事？乔治·布什和杀死小家伙有什么关系。好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·恩格斯。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）畅谈80年代的“快克”（快克可卡因）节目。澄清一下，84年对我和马克来说意义重大，不仅因为快克。我一整天都乐意谈论快克，但只是想让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，在这一点上，这是我们讨论快克的第二集节目。所以我开始看出一条贯穿线了。我们现在还讨论了艾滋病。谢谢你把那句话说完。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade. of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了致敬心理健康意识月，我带来了十多年的
I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
我在心理健康领域的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我在谈论。
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算做够了。因为人们会看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世上做一个好人很重要。你是因为害怕才做一个好人吗？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free, Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal.
我希望你真正地做一个好人。和我——基尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeart Radio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。
The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
随后的家事法庭听证会揭示了她故事中显而易见的不一致之处。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。欧文斯女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的税款被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, and Michael Marincini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges.
另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个同性恋，以及迈克尔·马林西尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。这还没结束，直到在亚利桑那州伸张正义。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So we know that trauma is felt in the body, we know that it's stored there. How exactly does that happen? How is this the case? Like what is actually happening in ourselves, in our muscles, in our stomach lining that makes this occur? The first way we need to understand this and the first theory we need to understand this through is something called polyvagal theory. It was developed by the American psychologist Stefan Porges.
所以我们知道创伤是在身体中感受到的，我们知道它储存在那里。这到底是怎么发生的？怎么会这样？我们的细胞、肌肉、胃壁里究竟发生了什么才导致了这种情况的发生？我们需要理解的第一个方式，也是我们需要理解它的第一个理论，叫做“多迷走神经理论”（Polyvagal Theory）。它是由美国心理学家斯蒂芬·波格斯（Stefan Porges）提出的，
and it is like the dominant theory explaining how exactly this comes to be. And the way that we can picture it is by imagining a ladder. Or even better, I want you to imagine one of those games that they used to have at old carnivals or fairs where you would get the hammer and you would hit it on like some sensor and this like little thing would fling up and you would hit different parts of, you know what I mean? like you would hit different parts, like, that would tell you how strong you were. Like, I'm hoping that you were getting what I'm saying. I, for some reason, I cannot give any more words as to how to explain this. Imagining it as a ladder, imagining it as this carnival toy thing,
它是解释这一切究竟是如何发生的主导理论。我们可以把它想象成一梯子来描绘它。或者更好的是，我想让你想象一下以前在旧狂欢节或游乐会上玩过的那种游戏：你拿着锤子敲击某个传感器，这个小东西就会飞起来，然后你会击中不同的部分，你知道我的意思吗？就像你会击中不同的部分，以此来告诉你有多强壮。我希望你能明白我的意思。不知为什么，我无法用更多的词语来解释这个了。把它想象成一架梯子，把它想象成这个狂欢节玩具。
if you know what I'm talking about. But at the bottom of this ladder, at the very base, we have what we call the ventral-vagal state. This is a state of your nervous system where you are deeply regulated. You're content, you're calm, you're grounded, you're connected, you're present with your environment, you're present with the people around you, you're able to respond and, you know, be kind of at peace, like you're just kind of existing. That is the bottom of the ladder. That is where we want to spend most of our time.
如果你明白我的意思的话。但在这个阶梯的最底部，也就是最底层，我们称之为腹侧迷走神经状态。这是你神经系统的一种状态，在这种状态下，你得到了深度的调节。你感到满足、平静、踏实、与外界有联系、活在当下、与周围的人同在，你能够做出反应，你知道的，就好像处于一种平和状态，仿佛你只是在单纯地存在。那是阶梯的最底层。那是我们希望花最多时间停留的地方。
Above that, on the ladder, we have the sympathetic state. Now, you may know the sympathetic state from the fight or flight response. This is where we experience a sense of tension. It's where all of our like survival mechanisms are kicking into gear. We may be afraid. We may feel threatened. We are scared. During a traumatic event, our brain's threat detection system goes into overdrive and pushes us into this state.
在这之上，在阶梯上，我们有交感神经状态。现在，你可能通过“战斗或逃跑”反应了解交感神经状态。这是我们体验到紧张感的状态。在这里，我们所有的生存机制都在启动。我们可能会感到害怕。我们可能会感到受到威胁。我们很惊恐。在创伤事件期间，我们大脑的威胁检测系统会进入超速运转状态，并将我们推入这种状态。
Adrenaline, cortisol. They're flooding our system. And our body is prepared to receive and respond to whatever danger or, threat it has already kind of recognized. In this state, this is like where you are having an intense stress response. That's not the top of the ladder though. At the top of the ladder, you have the dorsal vagal state where the body, it just stops fighting, just completely shuts down. You feel like you can't fight back. The situation you are facing is so awful that you are trapped, you're helpless. this is why you really feel like your life is threatened,
肾上腺素、皮质醇。它们正在充斥我们的系统。我们的身体已经准备好接收并应对它已经识别出的任何危险或威胁。在这种状态下，这就好像你正在产生强烈的应激反应。但这还不是阶梯的顶端。在阶梯的顶端，你有背侧迷走神经状态，此时身体停止了反抗，彻底关闭了。你觉得你无法反抗。你所面对的情况是如此糟糕，以至于你被困住了，你无能为力。这就是为什么你真的觉得你的生命受到了威胁，
your sense of safety is threatened, and unlike during the sympathetic state, there's nothing you can do about it. A healthy nervous system will rarely encounter the dorsal vagal state, if not hopefully ever. And instead, it typically jumps between the sympathetic state and the ventral vagal state, but it spends most of its time in the ventral vagal state.
你的安全感受到了威胁，而且与交感神经状态不同，对此你无能为力。健康的神经系统很少会遇到背侧迷走神经状态，如果不是希望永远遇不到的话。相反，它通常在交感神经状态和腹侧迷走神经状态之间跳跃，但它大部分时间都花在腹侧迷走神经状态上。
It responds to stress as appropriately, then it returns to that regular state. baseline. But someone who has experienced a deep trauma, they have gone all the way up the ladder. Think of it like a door has been opened. Like a whole new level is unlocked. The brain, now it can't forget that that new level, that new level of deep stress and just deep hopelessness is there. It can't forget what it felt like to just be in a state of complete overwhelm and it most certainly does not want to go back there. And yet, it often ends up going back there by being retrigured through memories,
它适当地对压力做出反应，然后恢复到那种常规状态，即基线。但是经历过深度创伤的人，他们已经一路爬上了阶梯。把它想象成一扇门被打开了。就像解锁了一个全新的关卡。现在，大脑无法忘记那个新关卡，那个深层压力和深层绝望的新关卡就在那里。它无法忘记那种完全不知所措的状态是什么感觉，而且它绝对不想回到那里去。然而，它往往最终还是通过记忆被重新触发，回到了那里。
through environmental cues, through any number of triggers. It starts to respond to minor things by swinging the stress state all the way up to the highest notch because it believes that that is what we have to do in order to survive. The process, the stress process, the nervous, system process has now become dysregulated and you will hear that word a lot when we talk about trauma and it's and how it relates to the body. The intense kind of energy caused by the stressful event, it basically gets us stuck or trapped in that highest gear and what we have experienced is not processed, it's not released, it's held, it's held there waiting for a signal of safety that
通过环境线索，通过各种触发因素。它开始对微小的事情做出反应，将压力状态一直飙升到最高档，因为它认为那是为了生存我们必须做的事情。这个过程，压力过程，神经系统过程，现在已经失调了，当我们谈论创伤以及它与身体的关系时，你会经常听到这个词。由压力事件引起的强烈能量，基本上使我们陷入或困住了最高档，而我们所经历的并没有被处理，没有被释放，它被保留着，被留在那儿等待一个安全的信号，而这个信号
often never comes. And so what you might find is that you're either in a state of constant arousal, a state of constant stress and hypervigilance, or you're in a state of complete numbness or emotional shutdown. Both of those estates that we do not want to be in. We want to be relaxed. We want to feel alert. We want to feel content. But the vagus nerve here, it is the key player. It is really what is trapping all of these experiences in like the deep nerves and the deep cells. and the deep responses of our body. This chronic state of dysregulation, it doesn't just stay in our vagal nerve.
往往永远不会到来。因此你可能会发现，要么你处于一种持续的唤醒状态、持续的压力和高度警觉状态，要么你处于一种完全麻木或情感关闭的状态。这两种状态都是我们不想陷入的。我们想要放松。我们想要保持清醒。我们想要感到满足。但这里的迷走神经是关键角色。它真的是把所有这些体验都困在深层神经、深层细胞、以及我们身体的深层反应中的罪魁祸首。这种慢性的失调状态，并不仅仅停留在我们的迷走神经中。
It doesn't just stay in our mind. The vagal nerve is the longest, biggest nerve in the whole body. It stretches almost the length of your body. And it's kind of like the highway through which all information is sent out. Now, imagine if that highway is blown up. Imagine if that highway is flooded, is swept away, is like something chaotic happens to that highway. If you want to get to anywhere else in the body and you can't take that highway and you can't take, you have to take back roads or there's no road available, connections or messages sent from the brain to the rest of the body to your limbs, to your stomach, to the muscles in your arms, they're kind of either not getting there or when the message.
它不只是停留在我们的头脑中。迷走神经是全身最长、最大的神经。它几乎延伸了你身体的整个长度。它有点像所有信息被发送出去的高速公路。现在，想象一下这条高速公路被炸毁了。想象一下这条高速公路被洪水淹没、被冲走，就好像这条高速公路发生了混乱的事情。如果你想去身体的其他任何地方，而你不能走这条高速公路，你不能走，你必须走乡间小路，或者没有可用的道路，从大脑发送到身体其他部位、你的四肢、你的胃、你手臂肌肉的连接或信息，要么没有传达过去，要么当信息
does get there, it's a bit scrambled and it's been a little bit shaken up and it's not the same message that was initially sent out. This chronic state of dysregulation, this is why we experience those physical symptoms that we acknowledge now are physical responses or the physical manifestations of trauma. It's why we get that muscle tension, the digestive issues, the chronic pain, the headaches, the jaw clenching, the unexplained autoimmune conditions, because our body is still in that state of hyper or hypo arousal, and also it just can't regulate every single system that's going on, because it still feels like it is in that really heightened stress response, and it is in that state of just complete helplessness where there's no point focusing on digestion. There's no point focusing on
传达过去时，它有点失真，被轻微摇晃过，而且已经不是最初发送出去的那个信息了。这种慢性的失调状态，这就是为什么我们会体验到那些我们现在承认是身体反应或创伤的身体表现的生理症状。这就是为什么我们会肌肉紧张、消化不良、慢性疼痛、头痛、下巴紧咬、原因不明的自身免疫性疾病，因为我们的身体仍然处于这种过度或低度唤醒的状态中，而且它只是无法调节正在进行的每一个系统，因为它仍然觉得自己处于那种高度升高的应激反应中，并且处于那种完全无助、专注于消化毫无意义的状态。专注于
our immune system. There's no point focusing on fighting off ill. There's no point in focusing on relaxing our muscles or feeling, you know, stable because it still feels like it's not going to survive. It still feels like there is this terrible thing that is happening to it. So let's talk about the pain component of this and the fact that a lot of people who have experienced trauma end up with chronic pain conditions. There is a very famous study. I don't know if it's famous.
我们的免疫系统毫无意义。专注于抵抗疾病毫无意义。专注于放松肌肉或感觉，你知道的，稳定下来毫无意义，因为它仍然觉得它不会生存下来。它仍然觉得有一件可怕的事情正在发生。所以让我们来谈谈其中的疼痛成分，以及许多经历过创伤的人最终患上慢性疼痛这一事实。有一个非常著名的研究。我不知道它是否著名。
Definitely I hope it becomes more well known, but it's a study that essentially found that in groups of participants who were experiencing chronic pain, the level of PTSD within those groups was significantly higher than in the general population. Up to 80% of people who reported chronic pain, who came to their GP or their doctor for chronic pain, had a previous personal history of PTSD or something that was deeply traumatic happening to them. Now, it wasn't just the kind of, it wasn't just physical trauma. So it wasn't like, oh, I have chronic pain because I was in a car accident,
我当然希望它能变得更广为人知，但这项研究本质上发现，在经历慢性疼痛的参与者群体中，这些群体中的创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）水平明显高于普通人群。多达 80% 报告有慢性疼痛、因慢性疼痛去看全科医生或医生的患者，都有过往的个人创伤后应激障碍史或经历过深刻创伤的事情。而且，这不仅仅是那种，不仅仅是身体创伤。所以它不像，“哦，我有慢性疼痛是因为我遭遇了一场车祸，
or I have chronic pain because I was, I fell out of a plane. A lot of these people had deeply interpersonal and emotional trauma that left no physical scars, but was obviously leaving real physical pain. The 2018 study published in the Canadian Journal of Pain Management looked into the physical symptoms of PTSD in 166 participants. And what they found was that almost half of the sample actually experienced pain flashbacks associated with memories of past events and trauma. So when they relived a past moment of trauma, they could tell you where they felt pain in their body.
或者我有慢性疼痛是因为我，我从飞机上摔下来。”这些人中的许多人都有深刻的人际关系和情感创伤，没有留下任何身体上的伤痕，但显然留下了真实的身体疼痛。2018 年发表在《加拿大疼痛管理杂志》（Canadian Journal of Pain Management）上的一项研究探讨了 166 名参与者的 PTSD 的身体症状。他们发现，几乎一半的样本实际上经历了与过去事件和创伤记忆相关的疼痛闪回。因此，当他们重温过去的创伤时刻时，他们可以告诉你他们在身体的哪个部位感到了疼痛。
And they would say, oh, I can feel this here. And I can feel this triggering something in me. And it is very, very intense for me. These are results, you know, you just, you can't ignore. those results, especially as they continue to be replicated time and time again, across countries, across population groups, across ages, across the type of trauma that people have experienced. Like, this level of pain or of physical discomfort is really an epidemic. So if trauma is so clearly and vividly present in the body, why are these very real symptoms
他们会说：“哦，我能在这里感觉到这个。我能感觉到这触发了我体内的某种东西。这对我来说非常非常强烈。”这些都是结果，你知道的，你只是，你无法忽视那些结果，特别是当它们在不同国家、不同人口群体、不同年龄、以及人们经历的创伤类型中，一次又一次地被复制时。像这样程度的疼痛或身体不适，真的已经成了一种流行病。因此，如果创伤在身体里如此清晰、生动地存在着，为什么这些非常真实的症状
and experiences often ignored, misdiagnosed, or just in general dismissed by society. I think it comes down to the fact that for a long time, the medical community approached health issues with a sense of mind-body duality. So basically the idea that the mind and the body, they are two separate things. They are two separate entities. If a physical symptom couldn't be explained by a clear organic cause, like a gaping hole in your arm, a broken bone, something of the sort. It was often dismissed as being in your head.
和经历却经常被社会忽视、误诊或总体上不予理睬？我认为归根结底是因为很长一段时间以来，医学界处理健康问题时带有一种“身心二元论”的感觉。所以基本上就是这样一种观点：心灵和身体是两回事。它们是两个独立的实体。如果一个身体症状无法用明确的器质性原因来解释，比如你手臂上有个大洞、骨折、诸如此类的事情。它经常被不屑一顾地认为只是你脑子里的问题。
But with the scientific access we now have, neuroscience has really debunked this idea, and it's provided very compelling proof that the pain is absolutely unequivocally, like it is real. Research using fMRI scans have shown that when people recall a traumatic event or they are triggered, the brain regions that process psychological distress overlap significantly with the brain regions that process physical pain. And I want to say this. Pain is not felt in the body. Pain is felt like in your mind. If people who are paralyzed and their nerves and their like their nerves below their waist or below wherever they don't work and someone stabs them in the foot, someone drops a cinderblank. lock on their foot, they're not going to feel it because there's no, like, that message isn't
但凭借我们现在获得的科学手段，神经科学已经彻底打破了这种观点，并提供了非常令人信服的证据，证明这种疼痛绝对是毋庸置疑的，它是真实的。使用功能性磁共振成像（fMRI）扫描的研究表明，当人们回忆创伤事件或被触发时，处理心理困扰的大脑区域与处理身体疼痛的大脑区域高度重叠。我想说的是：疼痛不是在身体里感觉到的。疼痛是在你的大脑里感觉到的。如果瘫痪的人，他们腰部以下或无论哪里神经不起作用，有人刺伤他们的脚，有人把煤渣砖掉落在他们的脚上，他们是不会感觉到的，因为没有，也就是说，那个信息没有
being sent to the brain. The brain is the home of pain. And so these fMRI studies are like so revealing that essentially all these receptors that we usually associate with physical pain are also being triggered by emotional experiences as well. Like the brain is literally processing this as a real physical threat. The vital point is, again, pain is, the pain is real. It may have an emotional, a mental, a psychological origin, but the pain receptors are being triggered in a very real way that will have us experiencing the sensation of pain.
被发送到大脑。大脑是疼痛的总部。因此，这些 fMRI 研究非常具有启发性，本质上，我们通常与身体疼痛相关的那些受体，也被情感体验所激活。就像大脑真的在把这当作一个真实的身体威胁来处理一样。至关重要的一点是，疼痛是，疼痛是真实的。它可能有情感的、精神的、心理的根源，但疼痛受体正在以一种非常真实的方式被触发，这将让我们体验到疼痛的感觉。
It is not in someone's head just because you can't point to a physical wound or a broken limb. I think another huge barrier in acknowledging this and getting help for this is shame. shame god it is like a plague on society shame just is like oh my god i think it just keeps so many people miserable and hurt when they don't have to be trauma you know especially when it's dismissed when it's unseen it really breeds this feeling of if i talk about this if people know this about me they will only see me as this they will see me differently they will walk on eggshells around me. They will cringe or be embarrassed at what I've been through. Like, there's always that voice that is saying, this isn't that serious. Don't ruin your reputation. Don't make people
仅仅因为你指不出一个身体伤口或断肢，它就不是在某人的脑子里。我认为承认这一点并为此寻求帮助的另一个巨大障碍是羞耻感。羞耻感，天哪，它就像是社会上的一场瘟疫，羞耻感就像是，哦天哪，我认为它让太多本不必痛苦和受伤的人保持痛苦和受伤。创伤，你知道的，特别是当它被忽视、当它看不见时，它真的会滋生这样一种感觉：如果我谈论这个，如果人们知道了我的这件事，他们只会把我视为这样的人，他们会用有色眼镜看我。他们会在我面前小心翼翼。他们会为我所经历的一切感到畏缩或尴尬。就像总有一个声音在说：这没那么严重。别毁了你的名誉。别让别人
uncomfortable. Don't make too big of a deal of this and it has to be, be silent, be quiet, deal with it. And guess what? It never works. The dealing with it is not actually dealing with it. It's just suppressing it. The shame, you know, it prevents people from seeking help because they're terrified of being judged. They're terrified of being seen as weak. They're terrified that they're going to speak about their trauma and someone's going to say, oh, that's not that big of a deal. Stop being so dramatic.
感到不舒服。别把这搞得太大惊小怪，必须保持沉默，安静点，自己消化它。结果呢？这根本不管用。消化它并不是真正的消化它。它只是压抑它。你知道的，羞耻感阻止人们寻求帮助，因为他们害怕被评判。他们害怕被视为软弱。他们害怕自己谈论创伤时，会有人说：“哦，那没什么大不了的。别那么戏剧化。”
There's also the real kicker to trauma in that you often have to re-trigger it to get through it. You have to talk about it. You have to expose yourself to things that you've avoided in a manner that's safe so that you can rewire that physiological and psychological reaction. That's bloody hard. If all that we're saying is true, reliving trauma, reliving the memories brings about real pain, then the path to healing is going to be painful.
创伤还有一个真正棘手的地方，那就是你经常必须重新触发它才能挺过去。你必须谈论它。你必须以安全的方式让自己暴露在那些你一直逃避的事情中，这样你才能重新连接那个生理和心理反应。这太难了。如果我们所说的一切都是真的，重温创伤、重温记忆会带来真实的痛苦，那么通往治愈的道路注定是痛苦的。
And sometimes people just don't want to go through that, which is totally, totally understandable. But I want to provide the silver lining in this very heavy conversation. There are some wonderful therapeutic techniques that minimize the pain as you are healing. and in the long term, that don't necessarily re-trigger you and leave you in that re-triggered space and can really, really help you. And I want to talk about some of the ones that have been introduced recently that maybe aren't spoken about that much and which are these new frontiers of how we manage mental pain as physical pain.
有时人们只是不想经历这一切，这是完全、完全可以理解的。但我想在这个非常沉重的话题中提供一丝光明。有一些很棒的治疗技术，可以在你治愈的同时将痛苦降到最低。从长远来看，它们不一定会重新触发你，也不会让你留在那个被重新触发的空间里，并且真的能对你产生很大的帮助。我想谈谈最近引入的一些方法，可能人们谈论得不多，它们是我们如何将精神疼痛作为身体疼痛来管理的新前沿。
Now, I will say one of my criticisms of the body keeps the score is that it presents these ideas and it kind of makes it seem that you can just like DIY this. You cannot. You cannot DIY this unless you have like gone through extensive training. There are so many amazing people who are experts in this who can guide you through these therapeutic techniques. We're just going to discuss them from a, from like a lens of psychoeducation and from a lens of like knowledge and just knowing they're out there, knowing they're available, knowing the core premise, knowing that they're not scary so that you can go and seek out someone who can help you with this at a deeper level. So I just have to put that little disclaimer in here.
现在，我要说的是，我对《身体记住了》（The Body Keeps the Score）的批评之一是，它提出了这些想法，并且让人觉得你可以自己DIY（动手做）。你不能。除非你接受过广泛的培训，否则你不能自己DIY。有那么多优秀的专家可以指导你完成这些治疗技术。我们只是从心理教育的角度，从知识的角度来讨论它们，知道它们的存在，知道它们是可用的，知道核心前提，知道它们并不可怕，这样你就可以去寻找能够更深入地帮助你的人。所以我必须在这里加上这个小免责声明。
But to dive in, a lot of trauma therapy these days is really about, thank gosh, really about integrating the mind and the body. And a large part of that may be talking about what occurred in the past, but it's equally about controlling how we respond physically and helping our nervous system feels safe so that it can return to a state of homeostasis and equilibrium. A really fantastic evidence-based therapy often recommended for people with PTSD or complex PTSD is called eye movement desensitization and reprocessing therapy or EMDR, which you may have heard of more recently. I feel like it's having a little bit of a moment because it is fantastic. This was actually developed by Francine Shapiro.
但深入来讲，现在很多创伤疗法实际上都是关于——谢天谢地——真正将心智和身体整合起来。很大一部分可能是在谈论过去发生的事情，但同样重要的是控制我们的身体反应，并帮助我们的神经系统感到安全，以便它能够恢复到体内平衡的状态。一种非常棒的、基于证据的疗法，通常推荐给患有 PTSD 或复杂 PTSD 的人，被称为眼动脱敏再加工疗法（EMDR），你可能最近听说过。我觉得它现在挺火的，因为它太棒了。这实际上是由法兰西妮·夏apiro（Francine Shapiro）开发的。
The story of how she came up with this therapeutic technique is actually, I like it. I think it's quite beautiful. She came up with it or discovered it, I guess, almost by accident. Like she was walking through the park one day and she was reliving or thinking about something that was deeply painful to her and traumatic to her. And she was moving her eyes side to side, like looking at birds and looking at plants and looking at the trees. And as she was doing it, she was like, wow, this actually feels like the intensity of this
她想出这个治疗技术的故事其实，我挺喜欢的。我觉得它相当美好。她几乎是出于偶然想出或发现它的。比如有一天她走在公园里，她正在重温或思考一件对她来说非常痛苦、对她来说是创伤的事情。她的眼睛左右移动，看着鸟儿，看着植物，看着树木。当她这样做的时候，她想，哇，这实际上感觉
memory is going down. Like, I'm really starting to feel better about this. So she took that experience. She did obviously a lot more research and put it into a lot of clinical applications, and she came up with EMDR, which uses the same principles. Specifically, it uses this method known as bilateral stimulation, which basically means both halves of your brain are active at the same time like a therapist will guide your eyes from side to side or will tap you on each side of your head as you are recalling a traumatic memory and it's thought to help the brain kind of reprocess and reintegrate this memory by moving it from the part of the brain that keeps it stuck and active so the amygdala to the part that stores it as a past event that can no longer hurt us
记忆的强度正在下降。天哪，我真的开始对此感觉好多了。于是她采用了这种体验。她显然做了更多的研究，并将其投入到许多临床应用中，她发明了 EMDR，它使用了相同的原理。具体来说，它使用了一种被称为双侧刺激的方法，这基本上意味着你大脑的两侧同时处于活跃状态，就像治疗师会引导你的眼睛左右移动，或者在你回忆创伤记忆时轻拍你头部的两侧，这被认为可以通过将记忆从将其保持卡住和活跃的部分（即杏仁核）移动到将其存储为无法再伤害我们的过去事件的部分（即海马体），来帮助大脑重新处理和重新整合这个记忆。
the hippocampus. When we experience something really overwhelming, our amygdala takes over. And our prefrontal cortex, the part of our brain that is responsible for executive thinking, rational thinking, it's basically demoted. That means that when we are retricored or something reminds us of the past, it can feel like it's happening right now all over again, leading the brain and the body to have that disproportionate response because it generally genuinely thinks like this is really happening. It doesn't recognize like, oh, this is, this is a memory. This isn't real. So EDMR helps us reduce the intensity of these memories by reducing activity in the brain's fear circuits whilst we actively recall this event so that it loses some of
当我们经历非常不知所措的事情时，我们的杏仁核接管了一切。而我们的前额叶皮层——我们大脑中负责执行思考、理性思考的部分——基本上被降级了。这意味着，当我们在被重新触发或某些事情让我们想起过去时，它可能会感觉就像现在再次发生一样，导致大脑和身体做出那种不成比例的反应，因为它真心觉得这真的正在发生。它没有意识到，哦，这是，这是一个记忆。这不是真的。因此，EMDR 通过在积极回忆这一事件的同时减少大脑恐惧回路中的活动，帮助我们降低这些记忆的强度，使其失去一些
its sharpness. The memory doesn't disappear. It's not like hypnosis. We're not trying to make you forget. It's just that the emotional and physiological charge, is neutralized in a way that allows us to recall it without the associated terror. So this is one of the ways that we can create psychological and physical safety for ourselves so that we can integrate our experience. We are going to take a short break, but then I want to talk about a few others, including one of my own favorite techniques that I have tried, that I love, that I could talk about for literal days.
尖锐性。记忆并没有消失。这不像催眠。我们并不是想让你忘记。只是情绪和生理上的负荷被中和了，使我们能够在没有相关恐惧的情况下回忆起它。所以这是我们为自己创造心理和身体安全感以整合我们的体验的方法之一。我们要休息一小会儿，但接下来我想谈谈其他几个，包括我尝试过、我很喜欢、我可以滔滔不绝讲好几天的我最喜欢的技术之一。
So stay with us. We will be right back. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inundated.
所以请继续收听。我们马上回来。2%。这是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健康和建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上是
inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
会引起炎症的。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。
That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with a little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
这就是可在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听的《TWO%》。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 上双击金·卡戴珊（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟金·卡戴珊到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you're just so you.
我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个时刻，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何挺过这一切的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的合作，大谈 80 年代的快克（crack）毒品。需要明确的是，84 年对我很重要，不仅因为快克。我随时都可以聊聊快克，但只是为了让你们，为了让你们
y'all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. So, you're finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast. Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month,
你们都知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始发现这里有一条主线。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在了桌面上。所以，你快把那句话说完吧。是的。我不认为有什么年份对黑人更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎收听我的新播客《从头学起》（Learn the Hardway），我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，
I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it,
我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在追逐它，
and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns. Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
却不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活成了关于赢输的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）。达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两个不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free, Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真的能做一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《从头学起》（Learn the Hardway）中，就治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的 IHeart Radio 应用。搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
这引发了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。你对某人伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才破案。我希望人们能看到他们的税款被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。
Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.
格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我的天哪。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱情陷阱》（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被以欺诈罪起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。
Listen to Love Trapped Podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So let's talk about a few other ways that people have studied, examined, and are trying to kind of help us integrate our trauma on an individual level. Now, I did acknowledge this before, but that is something about trauma that is very frustrating for many people. Trauma is often systemic. It happens within large systems. It happens between two or multiple people. yet it's so it's annoying we are kind of forced to heal from it individually it's very unfair there are definitely collective methods for this that are i think a little bit more underground collective trauma
在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trap Podcast》。所以让我们来谈谈人们研究、检查并试图以个人层面帮助我们整合创伤的其他几种方法。现在，我之前确实承认过这一点，但对于许多人来说，创伤有一个非常令人沮丧的地方。创伤通常是系统性的。它发生在大系统中。它发生在两个人或多个人之间。然而，令人烦恼的是，我们却被迫以个人身份从中恢复，这非常不公平。这肯定有一些集体的方法，我认为这些方法更偏向地下，即集体创伤
therapy support groups um things like yawning circles in australia these are practiced by first nations people where a group of people sit in a circle they share experiences they share knowledge advice support surrounded by their community but A lot of Western trauma therapy is definitely focused on the individual. There is a book I really want to read. It's on my bookshelf right now. It's called Very Appropriately Healing Collective Trauma. But we are mainly going to talk about individual methods here,
疗法支持小组，嗯，比如澳大利亚的“围坐倾谈圈”（yarning circles），这是原住民的做法，一群人围坐成一个圈，分享经验、知识、建议、支持，被他们的社区所包围。但许多西方创伤疗法绝对侧重于个人。有一本书我真的很想读。它现在就在我的书架上。书名非常贴切，叫做《治愈集体创伤》（Healing Collective Trauma）。但我们在这里主要讨论个人方法，
acknowledging that there is like a huge gap in the mental health and psychology and trauma space to try and help people in a collective community way, hopefully, and definitely without retrial. traumatizing them. It's definitely, I think, something that more research and more funding needs to get to be put into. Like, we need to stop thinking about trauma is just an individual issue and more as a community issue and one that can be helped with community. But back to these individual therapies, things like somatic therapies, for example, I still think they are really, really effective. The goal of these therapies isn't, you know, to retell the story of the trauma. It isn't to like
承认心理健康、心理学和创伤领域存在一个巨大的空白，即试图以集体社区的方式帮助人们，希望如此，而且绝对是在不进行二次创伤的情况下。我认为这绝对是需要投入更多研究和资金的领域。我们需要停止将创伤仅仅视为个人问题，而是更多地将其视为社区问题，一个可以通过社区得到帮助的问题。但回到这些个人疗法，例如身体疗法（somatic therapies），我仍然认为它们真的非常非常有效。这些疗法的目的不是，你知道的，去重述创伤的故事。它不是去
try and make it make sense because it never will. It's just to gently guide the body to let go of its defensive response and say, this doesn't have to make sense, but I'm still safe. Just because I don't have closure for this doesn't mean that I'm not in a space where I can let myself relax. One of these therapies is known as semantic experiencing, and it was founded by the psychologist and the author Dr. Peter Levine. So within this process, therapists,
试图让它说得通，因为它永远不会说得通。它只是温和地引导身体放下防御反应，并说：“这不一定说得通，但我仍然是安全的。仅仅因为我对此没有一个圆满的结局，并不意味着我不能让自己放松下来。”其中一种疗法被称为“躯体体验”（somatic experiencing），由心理学家兼作家彼得·莱文博士（Dr. Peter Levine）创立。在这个过程中，治疗师
use this thing called titration to guide a client to just feel or re-experience and really small manageable piece of the traumatic sensation in their body and then let it go. So it's like slowly releasing the pressure from a locked valve, tiny bits at the time so it doesn't all flood out, allowing the stored energy to kind of discharge itself bit by bit without overwhelming the system. Whilst Levine, I think he's definitely come under similar criticism. to Vandercalk, somatic experiencing really demonstrates at least some use in reconnecting with our bodies and understanding certain physical sensations so that we can feel in control of them, something that is often rubbed of people who have repeatedly experienced or been exposed to trauma.
利用一种叫做“滴定法”（titration）的东西来引导客户去感受或重新体验他们身体中微小、可控的创伤感觉，然后释放它。这就像慢慢释放锁死阀门的压力，一次一点点，这样就不会全部涌出，从而允许储存的能量一点一点地自行释放，而不会让系统超载。虽然莱文，我认为他肯定也受到了类似于范德考克的批评，“躯体体验”至少在重新连接我们的身体和理解某些身体感觉方面表现出了一定的用处，这样我们就能感到自己能够控制它们，而这往往是被多次经历或暴露于创伤中的人所剥夺的东西。
They don't feel in control of how their body reacts and their body responds, because it's operating on a different plane, as we know. When I was also looking into the research behind further body-based practices for trauma, I also came across a lot of evidence for yoga, which didn't surprise me. I have a friend who, one friend in particular I'm really thinking about, who has this like totally truly spiritual story about how yoga has helped her overcome some pretty terrible childhood trauma stuff. Every time she tells this story to me, like, I get chills and I get tears, like every
正如我们所知，他们觉得无法控制自己的身体如何反应，因为身体在不同的平面上运作。当我研究更多基于身体的创伤练习背后的研究时，我也发现了大量支持瑜伽的证据，这并不让我感到意外。我有一个朋友，我特别想到的一个朋友，她有一个完全真实的、精神层面的故事，关于瑜伽如何帮助她克服了一些相当糟糕的童年创伤。每当她给我讲这个故事时，我都，起鸡皮疙瘩，还会流泪，真的每次
single time. I think I've got to ask you to come on to the podcast and if she would be willing to talk about it. But it's just beyond brilliant. Yoga as a therapeutic technique, it's just groundbreaking. You know, for example, there was a 2014 study based in the US that looked at the effect of 12 sessions of yoga on a group of women with PTSD. And it compared their symptoms to those of people who didn't take part. And what they found was that those who completed the 12 sessions demonstrated less anxiety, less hyperarousal, and they reported that they had less pain and less mental discomfort or distress associated with re-experiencing their trauma on the day to day.
都这样。我想我得邀请你来上播客，看她是否愿意谈谈这件事。但这简直是太棒了。瑜伽作为一种治疗技术，简直具有突破性。你知道，例如，2014 年美国的一项研究观察了 12 节瑜伽对一组患有 PTSD 的女性的影响。它将她们的症状与没有参加的人进行了对比。他们发现，完成 12 节瑜伽的人表现出更少的焦虑、更少的高唤醒状态，并且她们报告说，与日常重温创伤相关的疼痛和心理不适或困扰更少。
And if we think of the crucial elements of yoga, it really makes sense. You know, the focused, controlled breathing, moving our bodies alongside other people. Again, maybe that's pointing to, again, a more collective way of managing trauma. Even like the stretching and the release of muscular tension, the flexibility, the sense of personal control and agency over our bodies, it all comes together to combat the negative side effects that stored trauma can cause. In a slightly different vein, personally, I found that running and weight lifting has had a similar effect for me.
如果我们考虑到瑜伽的关键要素，这就完全说得通了。你知道，集中、受控的呼吸，和他人一起移动我们的身体。再次强调，这可能再次指向管理创伤的更集体的方式。甚至像伸展和释放肌肉紧张、柔韧性、对身体的个人控制感和自主权，所有这些结合在一起，来对抗储存的创伤可能引起的负面副作用。以稍微不同的方式，就我个人而言，我发现跑步和举重对我也产生了类似的效果。
could never get into yoga but recently i feel like i talked about this on our run club episode i have just found like a new love for like endurance running i don't know where it came from it's it's not just the endorphins either it's this sense of of strength and power that i get from pushing myself traumatic experiences i think they make us feel so weak sometimes and powerless that's literally their very nature. And when I run, I feel so strong. I feel so capable. I feel a lot of the rage that I've been carrying kind of releasing itself into something that I can feel proud of and that I can see my body doing. I also trust my body more. I feel like my stress and my anxiety have lessened. There is this incredible podcast that I actually listened to on this the other day. I'm literally going to get my
我从来没有真正喜欢过瑜伽，但最近我觉得我在我们的跑步俱乐部那一集里谈过这个，我刚刚对耐力跑步产生了一种新的热爱，我不知道它是从哪里来的，而且这不仅仅是内啡肽，这是我从突破自我中获得的这种力量感和能量感。我认为创伤体验有时会让我们感到如此软弱和无力，这简直就是它们的本质。当我跑步时，我感到如此强壮。我感到自己如此有能力。我感觉到我一直携带的很多愤怒开始释放到我可以为之自豪的事情中，并且我可以看到我的身体在这样做。我也更信任我的身体了。我觉得我的压力和焦虑减轻了。前几天我在一个不可思议的播客上听到了关于这个的内容。我真的要拿出我的
phone up and I'm going to find it. It was with this running influencer that I follow called Maddie Runs and she lives in Utah and she sat down and talked to this person. I'm literally trying to find it. Here it is. It's from the Everyday Ultra podcast. It's called How to Heal Through Running and Build Self Belief with Madeline Wolf-Balgar. And I listened to that podcast and I was like, oh, this totally makes sense. This like physical connection that she's had with her body has allowed her trauma to be expressed.
手机来找它。那是和我关注的一个叫麦迪跑步（Maddie Runs）的跑步网红进行的，她住在犹他州，她坐下来和这个人交谈。我真的在努力找它。找到了。它来自《日常超级马拉松》（Everyday Ultra）播客。它叫《如何通过跑步治愈并建立自信》（How to Heal Through Running and Build Self Belief），嘉宾是玛德琳·沃尔夫-巴尔加（Madeline Wolf-Balgar）。我听了那个播客，然后我想，哦，这完全说得通。她与身体的这种身体连接让她的创伤得以表达，
in a way that she feels is manageable. When she's running, she feels so capable and she feels so in control that the negative thoughts can come up and she's still, she still is like, again, in control of her body and so they're allowed to be released. Incredible podcasts should absolutely listen to it. She is amazing as well. She's just really, really cool. But again, all of this is about connection. Breathwork is another one that people talk about a lot. We just did an episode on that with our expert guest, Jessica Dib. There's so much neuroscientical. science to all of this. There's so much neuroscience to the way that having a better physical relationship with our body allows us to build self-trust in the fact that we can handle the
以一种她觉得可以掌控的方式。当她在跑步时，她感到如此有能力，也如此能够掌控，以至于负面情绪可以浮现出来，而她依然，她依然，正如我所说，能够掌控自己的身体，所以它们被允许释放出来。不可思议的播客，绝对应该听听。她也很棒。她真的很酷很酷。但同样，这一切都关乎连接。呼吸法是人们经常谈论的另一个方法。我们刚刚和我们的特邀嘉宾杰西卡·迪布（Jessica Dib）录制了一集关于这个的节目。这一切背后都有太多的神经科学。拥有与身体的更好身体关系，使我们能够建立起自信，相信自己能够应对创伤的身体表现，这背后有如此多的神经科学。
physical manifestations of our trauma. And we can, we are in control. We are in charge, even if the emotional side of it doesn't make us feel that way. I think ultimately healing from trauma that is trapped in the body is about helping the body understand that the threat is over. That is like the line we keep coming back to. It's about building a sense of safety. Trauma is the disruption of safety. Coming back to your body, feeling safe in your body, therefore, I think just like undercuts all, like all the stories that trauma is telling us that we are not safe. You know, of course, we also have to give a shout out to like our cognitive and like our talk therapies as well for getting a lot of people to the point where they can have this semantic and physical approach. But
而且我们可以，我们掌控一切，我们负起责任，即使情感层面不让我们觉得是这样。我认为，归根结底，治愈被困在身体里的创伤，是关于帮助身体理解威胁已经结束。那是我们不断回到的核心观点。这是关于建立安全感。创伤是对安全感的破坏。因此，回到你的身体，在你的身体里感到安全，我认为这直接驳斥了所有创伤告诉我们的、我们不安全的谎言。当然，我们还得感谢我们的认知疗法和谈话疗法，它们让许多人达到了能够采用这种躯体和身体方法的程度。但
whatever you can do, whatever practice you can find that is going to allow you to realize that your mind and your body are in unison and that your emotional experiences show up physically in a way that is completely valid and completely real and completely felt that is going to help you. The body, like our body, like our body. body this is going to get kind of spiritual. It's like, but it is such a gift and it is such a vessel through which we can deepen our connection with our sense of self psychologically. It is like this domain and this tool that we have hopefully a lot of power over and that we can use as, I don't even know how to explain this. It's just something I've been really like really feeling deeper
无论你能做什么，无论你能找到什么练习，只要能让你意识到你的心智和身体是和谐一致的，并且你的情感经历以一种完全有效、完全真实、完全能感受到的方式在生理上表现出来，那对你就会有所帮助。身体，就像我们的身体，就像我们的身体，这会变得有点精神层面。这就像，但它真的是一份大礼，也是一个容器，通过它我们可以加深我们与心理上的自我认同的连接。它就像是这个领域和这个工具，我们希望对它有很大的掌控力，我们可以将它用作——我甚至不知道该怎么解释这一点。这只是我最近一直在真正、真正深刻感受到的东西，比如，天哪，伙计们，看我又要说回去了，但是，身体不是我们，但身体就像是我们的延伸，通过照顾它、通过更多地理解它、通过尊重它、通过像对待我们的大脑一样对待它，真的可以治愈我们。我觉得心理学在让我们理解创伤的精神层面以及我们的安全感和自我感方面已经做了很多工作。
and deeper recently, like the, my God, guys, look at me going to go, but like, the body is not us, but the body is like an extension of us that by taking care of, by understanding more, by treating with respect, by treating as, like, in the same way we treat our mind, can really heal us. I feel like psychology has done so much for allowing us to understand the mental side of trauma and how our sense of self and our sense of safety and
最近更加深入了，就像是，天哪，伙计们，看我去，但是，身体并不是我们，但身体就像是我们的延伸，通过照顾它，通过更多地了解它，通过尊重它，通过像对待我们的心灵一样去对待它，真的可以治愈我们。我觉得心理学在让我们理解创伤的心理层面以及我们的自我感和安全感方面做了很多工作
our sense of peace and our sense of harmony and our sense of meaning is disrupted by trauma. We need to like add this body piece into it and understand that again when these deep painful feelings cannot be expressed through the mind and are not allowed to be expressed maybe verbally or maybe mentally by thinking about them, they will find other ways to come out and the body is the body is like kind of the sacrifice at that point. So I hope that this episode is just allowed you to understand the mechanisms behind that better and what people mean when they say the body keeps a score or trauma restored in the body. Yeah, I don't know. I feel like once you understand this, you're just like, I see my life differently and I see my body differently. And hopefully you
创伤会打乱我们的平静感、和谐感以及对意义的感知。我们需要把身体这个部分加入其中，并再次理解：当这些深层的痛苦感受无法通过思维表达，无法被允许通过言语或大脑思考表达时，它们会找到其他方式宣泄，而身体在那种情况下就像是一种牺牲品。所以我希望这集内容能让你更好地理解背后的机制，以及人们说“身体会记住一切”或“创伤储存在身体里”是什么意思。是的，我不知道。我觉得一旦你理解了这一点，你就会觉得，我对生活有了不同的看法，对身体也有了不同的看法。希望你
go and check out some of those other resources that I've shared and those other people who talk about this a lot more excellently than I do and who have even more marvelous and incredible stories and facts and insights to share. If you have made it this far, leave a little emoji down below of what represents peace for you, the opposite of trauma, the opposite of pain. Where do you feel most at peace? What like, what symbolizes real contentment and safety for you. Thank you for listening if you did make it this far as well. I really appreciate when people make it all the way to the end to the end to my little rants and my little rambles and me going off script. So thank you. Make sure as well that you are following us on Instagram at
去看看我分享的其他一些资源，以及那些比我讲解得更出色、拥有更精彩、不可思议的故事、事实和见解的人。如果你听到了这里，请在下方留下一个代表你内心的平静、创伤的对立面、痛苦的对立面的小表情符号。你在哪里感到最平静？什么象征着你真正的满足感和安全感？如果你真的听到了这里，谢谢你的收听。我很感激有人能一直听到最后，听到我那些小唠叨、胡思乱想以及脱稿的话。所以谢谢你们。同时，请确保在Instagram上关注我们
That Psychology Podcast. If you already follow us, you know we do like episode summaries. We sometimes ask for episode suggestions. We announce tour dates. We do all that stuff over there that we don't always do on the podcast. Whoopsies, that's totally my fault. But follow me over there so that you can be engaged with the community. Make sure that you are following us as well on Spotify or Apple Podcasts, wherever you are listening and give us a five-star review. If this episode resonated with you, if you feel called to do so, make sure you take care of yourself. I know this episode was rather heavy. It was a bit of an info dump. It definitely was perhaps a little bit re-triggering if some of these concepts are ones that, you know, you don't always talk about and which are very heavy
That Psychology Podcast。如果你已经关注了我们，你会知道我们会做单集总结。我们有时会征求单集建议。我们会公布巡演日期。我们在那里做所有这些我们在播客中不常做的事情。哎呀，这完全是我的错。但请在那里关注我，以便你能参与到社区中来。确保你也在Spotify、Apple Podcasts或你收听的任何地方关注我们，并给我们五星好评。如果这集引起了你的共鸣，如果你觉得自己愿意这么做，请务必照顾好自己。我知道这一集相当沉重。它有点像是一次性灌输大量信息，如果其中有些概念是你平时不常谈论的、非常沉重的概念，那它绝对可能会重新引发一些触发
you. So I'm going to leave some resources below as well. But please, again, be kind to yourself, be gentle, take care of yourself. And we will, of course, talk very, very soon. See you later. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships. And you, you'll put yourself through some hardships. And you You will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
你。所以我也会在下方留下一些资源。但是，请再次对你自己好一点，温柔一点，照顾好自己。我们当然很快就会再聊。再见。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦。而你，你会让自己经历一些艰难困苦。而你，你会以一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己从另一端走出来。收听《2%》。
That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
就在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》播客。从1979年开始，对我和说那是我的一个重要时刻。84年对我也很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是怎么熬过这段日子的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. Before it was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。在它成为疯狂的一年之前。那是一个疯狂的一年。我认为没有哪个年份对黑人来说比这更重要了。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。
many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once.
许多男人都穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着仅仅因为你有这种能力，你就必须这么做，请在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下一对双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格、一个女同性恋者、迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一档IHeart播客。保证是由真人制作。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。